sie sind sieben bis 35 zentimeter groß
kosten zwischen 100 und knapp 700 euro
und sie stecken voller details sollten
in der jeans die brille selbst die
streifen im schal eine person bringen
sie zum vorschein
ein jahr lang hat timo schädel an der
entwicklung dieser figuren gearbeitet
ist eigentlich das familienporträt der
zukunft wir würden gerne das klassische
medium quasi das klassische medium der
fotografie erweitern um die dritte
dimension und seien völlig neuen
betrachtungswinkel schaffen
bis die miniaturen so aussahen haben der
werber timo schädel und seine
geschäftspartnerin christina neurohr
zahlreiche druckverfahren ausprobiert im
juni 2013 gingen sie dann mit ihrem
unternehmen twin kind an den start
3d zu tun gehabt aus der animationswerk
sozusagen und inspiriert durch die
möglichkeiten des 3d printing als ich
auf die multi color technologie gestoßen
bin stand plötzlich diese idee im raum
um zu sehen wie das genau funktioniert
stattet euromax moderatorin kristina
sterz der firma einen besuch ab
erster schritt das kennenlernen timo
schädel erfragt wünsche und erklärt das
prozedere dann kommt das fotografieren
im sogenannten scan ruhm gibt es 100
kameras die apparate sind so angeordnet
dass sie die person aus allen
erdenklichen blickwinkeln abbilden
können
in welche kamera und koks ist eigentlich
egal wir empfehlen aber so ein bisschen
auf diese höhe zu gucken damit seine
augen schon geöffnet sein das ist
eigentlich alles im bruchteil einer
sekunde schießen alle kameras
gleichzeitig ein foto am computer können
sie anschließend begutachtet werden
falls der kunde unzufrieden ist wird der
fotos gern wiederholt
das prinzip was dahintersteckt ist die
sogenannte photogrammetrie das ist also
die möglichkeit aus mindestens zwei
punkten gleichzeitig zu gucken und
daraus ein dreidimensionales objekt
errechnen kann eine spezielle software
verarbeitet die fotos zu einem 3d modell
mehrere stunden braucht der prozess
digitale handarbeit nennt der gebürtige
hamburger dass die figur soll
schließlich dem charakter der gescannten
person entsprechen
wichtigster teil der produktion der
druck im prinzip funktioniert einen 3d
drucker wie ein tintenstrahldrucker
statt papier wird hier aber gips pulver
verarbeitet für schicht einen pulver web
aufgeschichtet wo ein sogenannter binder
aufgebracht wird eher verhärtet diese
partikel mit farbe ohne und am ende des
druckvorgangs hat man im grunde genommen
das produkt in diesem großen pulver
volumen legen das reich schaufelt wird
nach rund fünf stunden wird mit dem
sauger das überschüssige material
vorsichtig entfernt zum vorschein kommt
kristina sterz als 3d miniatur ein
infield rat macht farben und details
sichtbar
dieses verfahren wollen die macher
künftig noch perfektionieren
das wollen wir letzten endes jetzt auch
erreicht und diese technik insofern
weiter zu entwickeln dass sie immer
detailgetreuer immer lebensjahr immer
schärfer wird
und darum bekommt kristina sterz ihre
mini doppelgängerin detailgetreu selbst
beim schmuck